[Music]
the soothing water dimmed lights all to
welcome the next patient inside the
zenden
good girl this 13 year old German
Shepherd is quite familiar with the
routine her pet parent May Wong has been
bringing a Scana here since December
like old dog problems and she couldn't
get up for two and a half weeks that is
until Pet Health Hospital owner Mark
berenstra started treating Escada with
acupuncture we use acupuncture for dogs
and cats and and for a variety of
different conditions whether that be
pain management
arthritis GI issues respiratory issues
the ancient Chinese believe illness is
caused by an imbalance of energies
within the body acupuncture restores
those energies and promotes healing
you're fine ascana is being treated by
Dr Renee Lewis today don't stress them
out any more than they might be when Pet
Health opened eight years ago there was
only one vet certified in acupuncture
but today the hospital has five Baron
straw says about 15 percent of the
animals who have chronic issues or
chronic illnesses like a Scana receive
it our pet parents love that aspect of
practice because like I said it is
non-pharmaceutical it's different and
also I think our pet parents see the
benefit and see the results I know it's
the chi that's working on her yeah the
circulation the energy the blood
circulation and all that yeah
acupuncture is typically cumulative so
repeated episodes have a benefit when
askana first arrived at Pet Health the
Vets here had to carry her it but now
she manages all on her own after the
second time she was able to get up and
walk